il existe un très joli pièce d'ouverture
contre le gambidam avec les noirs pour
gagner une pièce on joue des quatre donc
des 5 C4 E6 cavalier C3 jusque là c'est
naturel on vient défendre notre pion et
sur le clouage au lieu du classique
fouet pour se déclener on va tendre un
piège au blanc en jouant une cavalier
des desserts à première vue les Blancs
ont l'impression qu'ils vont gagner un
pion en profitant du clouage sur le
cavalier 5 est une faute là on les
compte directement cavalier prend dessin
on laisse Notre Dame et après fu pandam
on vient se venger sur la dame adverse
grâce à cette échec de derrière les
fagots la dame est obligée de se
sacrifier on la mange sur échec le roi
reprend et derrière on vient récupérer
le fou et c'était la fin du bal qu'on
paie les musiciens là on compte on a un
cavalier de plus que les blancs et c'est
donc une finale facilement gagner non